[Music]
imagine a river hot enough to kill you
said to be the home of a powerful
Amazonian water spirit that place is
real and I've been there
it's the shine I think Mishka the
boiling River of the Amazon
[Music]
my name is Anthony Russell and I am a
geothermal scientist and conservationist
as a boy in Lima my grandfather told me
this crazy story about the search for
the lost city of gold
there was a detail on a story about a
river that boiled I certainly imagined
it but never never really dwelled on it
it was just the detail
turns out this place is real so the
boiling River is located in the heart of
the central Peruvian Amazon the hottest
temperature I've measured was over 210
degrees Fahrenheit
to put that into everyday terms the
average coffee is roughly 130 degrees
it's hard to physically imagine that
much hot water you stick your hand in
and you will see second with
third-degree burns
a matter of seconds I've seen a number
of animals fall into the boil remember
everything from birds to reptiles
complex organisms like us we don't do
well at those high temperatures we
literally start to cook on the bone
feeling that heat come into you
breathing in this thick hot air where
you can feel the air heating you up
inside your nose you can feel it going
into your lungs you can feel the
presence of your lungs because of the
heat of the air Ayad still gives me
goosebumps
the true name of the boiling river is
shun I think beach town and that means
according to one of the local shamans
boiled with the heat of the Sun it's
spectacular it's this place is totally
redefined what it means to be sacred for
me I think once you've experienced
something that's truly moved you you
love it and you can't let that go
[Music]